[Music]  let's make bang bang shrimp toast  that is so good get your shrimp  crush it and chop it nice and fine and  some cilantro  okay now we have our shrimp potato  starch garlic powder kosher salt chopped  cilantro and one whole egg white and  give that a good mix mix until it's well  Incorporated and we're gonna add our  sesame oil mix again and we have our  classic white bread as much as it paints  me you have to remove the crust I get  that shrimp and spread it evenly at the  top make sure to clean the sides and it  should look like that nice and even I'm  just brushing it with melted butter now  I'm just going to bake this in the oven  until the bread is nice and toasted and  the shrimp is fully cooked you can also  fry it but I find it too oily so I  prefer to bake it but it's up to you now  that looks delicious okay for the bang  bang sauce mayo and sweet chili sauce  now dip it in a creamy sweet chili sauce